also wir haben gerade wir müssen gerade
klären hier war ein zwischenruf der
vermutlich einen ordnungsruf für den ter
kollege lehnt bis sie bis sie zu ende
gesprochen haben haben es geklärt sie
haben das wort der präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn es nach
einigen in diesem hohen hause und nach
einigen außerhalb dieses hohen hauses
geht steht vor ihnen jetzt ein unmensch
ein vertreter der menschenwürde ein
rassist oder wie wir es eben gehört
haben
ein anderer an die afg und ein anbieter
an den rassismus ich muss mich an diese
vorstellungen erst mal mit irritation
gewöhnen aber sie ist nicht ganz neu
aber sie ist irritierend für jemanden
der auch weil er sich jahrelang versucht
einzusetzen für geflüchtete für fragen
der seenotrettung weil er mit einem
youtuber zu der frage ein interview
gegeben hat mit mord rom und einem
kopfgeld konfrontiert ist und mit
alltäglichen hass schreiben das ist die
realität in diesem land wenn auch
mitglieder auch dieses bundestages heute
nicht wagen freiheits abgeordneten
abzustimmen weil sie angst haben dass
aktivisten ihre büros angreifen oder
zerstören ist glaube ich etwas nicht
richtig und wenn sie es gemerkt haben
sollten
wenn der um mann besteht dass ich hier
auf meinen eigenen biografie verweise
wenn ich also mich genötigt fühle und
viele andere hier auch in den letzten
tagen sich zu rechtfertigen und wenn sie
konfrontiert werden mit über die grenze
gehen den moralischen
erpressungsversuchen dann stimmt etwas
nicht dann ist etwas nicht in ordnung
ich begrüße es ja und es kennzeichnet
und würdigt unsere demokratie dass so
viele menschen in diesen tagen zuvor
sich für menschenrechte und
menschenwürde einsetzen dass sie es laut
tun und dass sie auch gegen ihre
einschränkung kämpfen
aber wenn dieser durchaus gut gemeinte
idealismus in der debatte zum
absolutismus wird dann stirbt die discos
fähigkeit und dann stirbt die fähigkeit
zur fairen auseinandersetzung mit der
kraft des argumentes es ist sehr wichtig
und auch verständlich dass wenn es um
abschiebungen geht umfrage der in
gewahrsam nahm
wenn es darum geht dass menschen
abgeschoben werden das wieder emotional
werden es geht schließlich um
existenzielle schicksal und fragen die
uns berühren
aber wenn wir eine situation erreichen
der reihen emotionalität in der
sachlichkeit und fairness sondern
auseinandersetzung nicht mehr möglich
ist dann stirbt auch jede form der
ehrlichkeit und differenzierte
auseinandersetzung die wir dringender
denn je in der frage von migration und
asyl gebrauchen können
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen gerade auch auf
grundlage international und nationalen
rechts müssen wir im stande sein um
gerade nicht getrieben zu sein des
rechtspopulismus über fragen von
migration und asyl auf der ebene von
kompromissen von entscheidungen und von
einer diskurs kultur in dem anderen
nicht moralisch defizitär zu sein
vorwirft ist zu diskutieren
das ist grundvoraussetzung einer
selbstbewussten souveränen demokratie
und deshalb werde ich wie auch viele
abgeordnete die sie vor in adressiert
haben in diesem haus nicht wegen und
nicht trotz dieser moralischen und weit
unter die gürtellinie gehenden anwürfe
entscheiden sondern aufgrund einer
bewussten entscheidung auf eine
entscheidung für eine eindeutig
unzweifelhaften sozialdemokratische
migrationspolitik die sich deutlich in
diesem heute zur entscheidung stehenden
migrations paket einschließlich das
geordnete rückkehr gesetzes ausdrückt
die kollegin mechanisch würde gerne eine
zwischenfrage stellen da sie und hin
jetzt mein redefluss unterbrochen haben
und da ich wie ich eben begründet habe
für eine dose stehe sag ich ja herr
kollegin wenn sie wenn sich ein kollege
zu einem zwischenruf meldet muss ich den
redner fragen und ich bitte sie das
nicht als eine unterbrechung des redners
hier zu würdigen das geht so auch nicht
mehr mit allem und springt da wird er
die kollegin mechanisches wort seiner
frischen frage herr kollege lind sie
sagten ja gerade selber sind an einem
sachlichen diskurs interessiert aber
dann können sie mir vielleicht mal
erklären wenn sie so ein großes
interesse daran haben warum sie dann
hier ein verkürztes verfahren
praktizieren warum wir erst am montag
marathon anhörungen macht
von expertinnen und experten und jetzt
heute am freitag bzw in dieser
sitzungswoche dass sie im
hauruck-verfahren durchs parlament
bringen ohne dass in aller gebotenen
aktiv für ordentlich beraten zu können
das erklären sie mir mal bitte wenn ihr
interesse an einem sachlichen diskurs in
all diesen fragen so unermesslich groß
ist ich sage ich danke ihnen sehr für
diese frage es wurde ja am anfang in der
geschäftsordnungsdebatte mehr als
deutlich gemacht dass wir uns absolut im
rahmen der parlamentarischen flogen
heiten und unserer vorgaben bewegen und
sie haben die antwort selbst gegeben
wir wollen selbstständig entscheiden und
zwar schnellstmöglich dieses dringend
notwendige gesamtpaket auf den weg
bringen wir wollen vor beginn des
ausbildungsjahres die möglichkeit haben
dass wir eine ausbildungs und
beschäftigungsbereich dass wir in einer
situation aufgeheizter diskussion in der
es eben nicht nur 22 organisationen gibt
die verständlicherweise sich aufregen
und kämpfen für diejenigen für die sich
einsetzen dass es aber auch viele viele
22 gibt in meinem wahlkreis und anderswo
die nachfragen wann sorgt hier für
ordnung in der migrationspolitik die
fragen wie wird sichergestellt dass
unverschuldet und verschuldet an ihrem
ausreizung behinderte unterschieden
werden die danach fragen wie klären wie
das faktische problem der
identitätsfeststellung und das ist
politische aufgabe politische aufgabe
ist gestaltung und politische aufgabe
ist es nicht uns hier
verschwörungstheoretiker zu unterstellen
wir würden aus irgendwelchen
koalitionsrunden etwas durchpeitschen
wollen
und ich frage sie noch was weil sie ja
das permanent im modus des moralischen
machen wenn sie hier und an das gute
recht sich so aufzuregen
bei jeder frage von abschiebungen uns
vorwerfen wir brechen die menschenrechte
warum schieben sie dann ab in baden
württemberg warum ist das in hessen die
praxis warum
hat die jamaika koalition in
schleswig-holstein ein abschiebehaft
gesetz beschlossen bei dem übrigens auch
kinder und familien aus mauerfall
inhaftiert werden können das werfe ich
ihn nicht vor aber diese doppelmoral
werf ich vor
es ist gut es ist gut für rechte zu
kämpfen
aber manchmal gibt es einen ganz
schmalen grat zwischen gerechtigkeit und
selbstgerechtigkeit es ist gut
wurde zu betonen
aber es gibt eben so und ich habe mir
das lange genug in unzähligen
ausschusssitzung angehört es gibt eben
auch einen sehr schmalen grat zwischen
heiligkeit und scheinheiligkeit und der
ist hier überschritten
häufig
hoffe ich sehr
dass wir bei aller unterschiedlichkeit
der position endlich einmal wieder in
der lage sind uns pragmatisch und
humanitär mit der zentralen
zukunftsfrage der migration auseinander
zu setzen und wenn wir nicht wollen dass
angrenzen generell zurückgewiesen wird
was wir eben nicht von sozialdemokraten
wenn wir kein neues know-how nach modell
australiens wollen wenn wir nicht wollen
dass europa zur festung mit mauern wird
und wenn wir erst recht nicht wollen
dass menschen mit mehr verrecken weil
wir die seenotrettung finden dann wenn
wir all das nicht wollen müssen wir eben
nicht nur fluchtursachen bekämpfen
sondern wir müssen auch dafür sorgen und
menschen in der zukunft davon abhalten
die keine perspektive haben in diesem
land eine aufnahme zu finden die keine
perspektive auf asyl haben sich in die
hände von schlitt wort zu begegnen und
sich auf die reise zu machen
das ist
münchen
mindestens so und tragen ihre angriffe
kollegin linda achten sie bitte darauf
dass ihre redezeit zu ende gegangen ist
in diesem wenn die cdu csu fraktion in
ein bisschen redezeit gibt aber ich
werde es bei den nächsten folgenden
redner abziehen
deshalb will ich nicht unsolidarisch
sein ich appelliere nur alle im einsatz
hier dafür dass wir den chor diskurs
nicht weiter vergiften uns genauso eine
pragmatische humanitäre politik
einsetzen und es vielleicht beim
nächsten mal schaffen das nicht so viele
abgeordnete hier unter solchen szenarien
und solchen inakzeptablen bedingungen
der moralische unter druck sitzung
entscheiden müssen vielen dank
[Applaus]